in this video we will talk about open
source and why you should care about
open source not only improve your
technical skills but also your
communication and networking skills
so you can get the jobs and client and
money that you deserve
we will cover git and the platform
github and go through
all those tabs you see across the top we
will also talk about how you can find
open source projects to contribute to
how to contribute
using the github ui how to make your
issues and pull requests and your github
profile pop so you can stand out from
the crowd
how you can make money from open source
directly and indirectly
hi my name's eddie and i've been a full
stack developer for over 15 years
i have a youtube channel that focuses on
open source if that sounds interesting
to you
the link is in the description below
head over to my channel and subscribe
and hit the bell so you get notified
every time i post a video
in this video we will start off with the
basics and then we'll go through to the
more advanced features
if you want to skip ahead there are the
timestamps in the description below
don't skip just yet even if you're an
experienced developer i'm sure there are
some tips you'll pick up
in the more basic sections and if you
have any tips or any feedback anything i
say please leave a comment below and i
will reply
open source is social coding so it's
like social media but on steroids
on places like instagram people can like
your pictures they can comment
and re-share on github people can not
only
style your project comment on your code
fork your project to share it
but they can also contribute back they
can make improvements
we can stand on the shoulder of giants
on other awesome projects to make
even better projects and then we can
contribute features and bug fixes
back to that original project even if
you're not contributing to open source
just yet i'm sure
you're using open source projects why
you should care about open source
because you're probably using a lot of
open source if not
all the tools and projects you're using
are probably open source
and it's great that you're using these
amazing open source tools but they're
only there and available because of
people like you
who contribute to them and you may think
oh i'm not an expert to contribute to
any of the big projects like react for
example but your fresh pair of eyes can
add so much
value to any project have you ever been
reading some documentation
and you've read step one okay i've done
that step two
done that step three oh how did i get
there i think there's a missing step
by you adding that step and contributing
back
will not only allow you to improve
your documentation skills to improve
your communication skills to network
with other developers future employers
it also help other people in the
community it will also probably help you
as well further down the line when you
come to use that project again and you
forget about that step you check the
documentation and it helps you
that's happened to me multiple times in
addition to that it's becoming
more and more important companies
recruiters are now looking
on github to find people and they're not
looking for the best coders
a lot of them actually looking for the
right attitude
are people getting involved in the
conversation can they collaborate with
other people
can they give constructive criticism
back to say someone's work
but also be supportive at the same time
these are skills
in addition to coding and that's really
important what a lot of these companies
look for now
so do get involved in the discussion on
github and i'm going to take you through
how you can do that on other platforms
for example like linkedin you can write
anything you want this is why
cvs and linkedin aren't that useful
github is becoming
more and more useful and you don't have
to contribute
massive amount of work little and often
it's like brushing your teeth
you brush your teeth every morning and
evening if you miss one morning
or one evening your teeth aren't going
to fall out it's not going to go black
but
over time your teeth stay healthy the
same thing with open source do a little
and often
therefore your github profile stays
healthy and then people can discover you
from different projects that you've
contributed to
other conversations that you've got
involved in you're probably more
familiar with this process on places
like twitter how you discover people how
people
discover you github is just the same and
it's a great way to get discovered
from your future employer or your future
client so i've mentioned
git and github let's talk more about
that let me start with git
because that underpins github there are
many source control management systems
but git is on steroids it not only has
additional save points where you can
save your work as you go along
each time you're happy with it therefore
if you make a mistake you can go back to
your previous save point
and source control management systems
also have branching so you can create a
copy of the work
and prototype create spikes practice do
certain things and still have those save
points
but only bring them back in for the rest
of the team to use once you're happy and
ready for it the big main advantage of
git is it's very efficient
very fast it's distributed which means
you can work
offline and just reconnect when you get
internet connection again later on
and you can do things like rebase which
is like rewriting history
so git is a great tool for collaboration
so what is github
github is built on top of git and gives
you so
many powerful features which means you
can use git via their web platform
but also you get issue tracking you get
project boards that are like trello
boards
you get continuous integration which
they call github actions
i'm going to show you that all shortly
you know what let's go to my computer
and dive straight into it
so now let's head over to github now you
can see you've got github behind me
this is my profile page on github and
i've got a customized profile page which
you can do by creating a repository
the same name as your username you can
see some of my highlights on my
achievements i'm a github star
the organizations that i belong to
sponsors that i have and the people that
i sponsor what you're probably more used
to seeing
is the pinned repositories and your
green activity bar and this is what
companies use to discover you
that's why it's really important to be
part of one organization be part of a
community
and to contribute to projects so let's
pick a project and let's contribute to
it so i can show you how you can easily
make a contribution to other projects as
we're on free codecamp's youtube channel
i thought it'd be important to pick a
free code camp project
so let's start from the top and work our
way down the page and then we'll make a
contribution
as you can see in the top right we have
people that are watching the project
that means for every change that happens
on the project they'll get a
notification
and the notification depends on how they
set up their notifications in their
account
so some people will be email some people
would be notifications stars are like
people who have favorited the project
like bookmarked it and they'll get
notifications in their github feed so
not
notifications that they've been tagged
the notifications in their github feed
forks are people who have made a copy of
the project
into their own account so they can make
changes and we're going to do that
shortly so stay tuned and then we have
the tabs along the top we have code and
that's the default tab that you land on
and you can see the code underneath and
you can navigate around
between the code you can see the files
you've also can switch between branches
branches are taking a copy of the code
base and allowing you to make
changes to that without affecting
everybody else on the project
so we usually use branches a lot that
are short-lived for a feature branch a
spike branch a bug fix a branch and
they'll get murdered into the mainline
branch via a pull request when it's been
reviewed
tags and releases allow you to create a
save point in your code base that can
never change
similar to a commit a release or a tag
is higher up in that
it will contain multiple commits and you
usually name them like v0 1.2
we can add a file we can do a lot
through the github ui
i can even open in codespaces which is a
new beta feature coming out in github
which allows you to have your entire
development environment in the browser
or
in vs code locally but actually
communicating with a server
on github that means you don't have to
worry about installing node a certain
version or python a certain version it
will just
work which is a game changer so when
that comes out any day now
for everybody else it is going to be
really awesome it's really going to
lower the barrier to
everyone contributing to open source and
then we can see at the top the last
commit that happened it was five hours
ago we can even click on the git hash
and see the exact changes that happened
at that point
so hopefully you're seeing how powerful
git and github are
and also you can see the commits the
commit is the entire
history of changes and we can see who
made it this is why it's important to
give your commit an
informative descriptive but concise so
short
title so when looking through the
history it is really easy to see what
happened
and then you can find the one that you
want and then you can click on the get
hash where you can actually go see more
details about what changed when making a
commit message
don't forget you can also give a
description if you want to add more
information
if you want to make changes to your
project or somebody else's i think it's
really important for you to raise an
issue
an issue is an action point or starting
a discussion
saying to someone there's a typo in your
project there's missing documentation or
there's a bug
this is how i found it and these are the
changes that i think should be made
that's really important the changes
could come from you or from someone else
that's the next step but raising an
issue
helps you get that green square on your
github profile and also adding comments
so replying to issues is really a great
way to get involved with a project into
the community get on their radar
so when they are looking to hire people
they're going to look at people who
contribute
to the project so you'll be first on the
list this is the issue section on github
and it's a great way to start the
conversation on your idea or the bug you
found or the enhancement that you want
and not only that it's a great way for
you to get involved in the conversation
on
other issues so do have a search do
filter the issues
for any issues you raise you still get a
green square on your github profile
issues have labels and the great thing
about these are if you want to fix a bug
or if you want to find something more
challenging where help is wanted or if
you want to find one that's a bit easier
another label to look for is good first
issue and you can click on these and it
filters them
so now they've been filtered down let's
say if i want to create a new issue
i hit on new and some projects have
templates
that means they'll pre-populate the
description field let's pick one for
example
bug report as you can see in the
description it's pre-populated
and it's asking for certain bits of
information if the issue you're raising
doesn't fit into any category
for example like this video then you can
open a blank issue
and it looks like this and if you're not
too familiar with markdown yet don't
forget you have got these helpers along
the top and it's always important to add
the description
and then when you've written something
in the description you can preview it to
see what it looks like
if you're a project maintainer you can
assign to people you can add a different
labels and projects and so on those are
things i can't do because it's not my
project
as you can see people can leave comments
below and the conversation can get
started
that's really important to have that
conversation with the community and with
the project maintainers
next is where it gets really exciting is
the pull request tab
and to raise a pull request you need to
make a change in another branch
and that sounds scary but i'm going to
show you how straightforward it is and
how simple you can do it
in the github ui so these are open pull
requests so if i click on one
we can go have a look at the changes so
someone's written a good description
it's got
checklists of things that they've done i
want to show you that in the markdown
section how you can do that and you can
see more commits have gone in
and another comment and all from a bot
has also been uh
applied and you can see the commits that
have happened you can see the checks
that have occurred
and we can also see the files that have
been changed the red ones are the ones
that have been taken out and the green
ones with the lines that have been added
and then in dark
red and dark green show you specific
characters that have been changed
and if you don't like this linear view
you can switch to split view
which shows the changes side by side
let's make a change this project so to
contribute to a project
let's find the file and the change we
want to make using the github ui is very
straightforward
if i go to the git ignore i notice some
inconsistency with the formatting
so it's a silly change but it will show
the process for you
and still adds value to the project
that's what you need to think about when
making changes
is it's about adding value to a project
so you can see between all the sections
there's one line gap
between this section there's actually
two so is it inconsistent i'm going to
make a change to remove that extra line
to do this you hit the edit button at
the top right
and github will automatically fork the
project for you
to create a fork for this project for
you to commit your proposed changes to
submitting a change will write it to a
new branch in your fork so you can send
a pull request i suggest adding a title
that makes sense from your changes
now i hit propose change and github has
automatically taken me to the pull
request
page with it pre-populated if you come
directly to the pull request tab
and you have a branch that you want to
create pull requests from remember to
click
compare across forks but github in this
situation knows i'm coming across from a
fork so it's already pre-populated that
for me
i can see the changes that i made i
remove this extra blank line
and now i can go create pull request and
once i've gone through their template or
put in some information if there isn't a
template
i can hit create pull request and if you
want to make any changes you can
click on the three dots and hit edit and
make changes to
the description if you want to make
changes to the code you can go to files
changed
and you can also hit edit any future
commits that you make to this branch
will automatically get added to this
pull request
while it's still open if it's closed
then you'll have to raise a new pull
request
if i head over back to my account and go
to the repositories
you can see the free code camp repo or
project is also
now in my account and it says that it's
forked from
free code camp free code camp so i can
actually follow
back to the original repository and
people can find me from that repository
so again it's social coding site people
can then discover you and discover
projects via different people in
different organizations
the actions tab is effectively
continuous integration on steroids
also known as ci and every time there is
an event
or a change this will run some actions
hence why it's called actions
actions can be tasks that run linters
that check your code
or automate a test to also check the
code through to sending notifications to
slack or discords
actions is driven by a yaml file and
it's really
really awesome so that's one thing i
also highly recommend you getting into
and actually github has a marketplace
for actions so you can see it almost has
five and a half
thousand actions for free that you can
use on your projects from sending
notifications to linking different
platforms together
and you can even write your own custom
github action in javascript or another
language
if you click on one of these actions on
one of these jobs
you can then see what is going on and
you can see the different steps
so if there is a failure you can dig
deeper and find out what went wrong
the great thing about this automation it
removes having discussions about
little things and then you get to focus
on the more important discussions
on actually adding value to each other
and learning from each other
in the security tab there are
suggestions for your project on
improving
the security do have a look at that do
click on it you can get more information
also in the insights tabs it gives you
insights on the project
on the contributors on the community
you'll notice that a lot of projects
are missing these steps and you can
contribute to the project by adding a
code of conduct by adding
an issue template etc the last two tabs
i want to show you
are discussions tab this is a beta
feature that is coming out
very soon and it's really awesome so it
still uses markdown just like issues but
it's like issues on steroids
because you could have threaded
conversations think of forums
people can ask a questions it can be a
question and answer
it could be general it could be ideas
could be show and tell and also a new
feature coming out shortly is for
different projects to create different
categories
but people can reply people can mark an
answer as accepted
and then people continue the
conversation
in underneath each other so you can have
different threaded conversations
the last tab on github i wanted to show
you is the projects tab
this might look familiar this might look
like the trello board
you can create different columns they
have templates that you can use this is
the kanban one where you've got to do
in progress in review and done and these
are the
issues that we created earlier and when
we can drag and drop them
between different sections as we work on
them and that's really good for people
to see the progress of the project
and if you want to add an issue from
here directly you can add a note and
then convert it to an issue very simply
one more tab that is interesting is the
wiki tab it allows you to write markdown
markdowns mentioned everywhere as you
notice and have your documentation in
the wiki section and it's a wiki
underneath is actually a git repo so
when you learn how to use
a git repo on the main repository on the
main project you can actually use it on
the wiki 2.
i've actually honestly started using the
wikiless not because
i don't think documentation is important
actually i think it is very important
but i actually started putting the
documentation in the code base under the
docs folder
and the reason for that is when i add a
new feature to the project
i actually add the documentation as part
of that change as part of that pull
request
so when someone's reviewing the code
changes the automated test changes they
can also review the documentation
changes and that just keeps the quality
of the project
really high but the wiki can also be
used for documentation it depends on
your project and your team
i highly recommend if it's an open
source project putting documentation in
the repo under the locks folder
because then it can go through a pull
request and get reviewed and not only to
get reviewed but also to get knowledge
transfer
between the team members and the
community so now you know how to use
github let's talk about
how to find a github project that you
can contribute to
you can contribute to any project but
let me show you some tips and tricks on
how to find ones that are more inclusive
more
welcoming i mentioned some labels if you
go to the issue tab
on any repository you can filter by the
issue like first timers only
but that limits you to one project
another thing you can do is the issues
at the top
on github you can then see all the
issues that you've created or been
assigned
but you could also filter github
by a label so it's label colon
hacktoberfest you can do this by
clicking on any label so if you want to
filter by good first issue
you can click on filter by good first
issue now you can see all these
different projects
that have got a label with good first
issue
another really good way to find projects
is on twitter the people you follow
maybe they mention some inclusive
projects that want some contribution
that will help you and mentor you get up
to speed with their project
you're probably already using libraries
in your project or using a framework
you'll know those quite well or you've
probably noticed
bugs are missing documentation those are
also good projects to contribute to
a real secret tip before contributing to
a project that you're thinking about
contributing to
is actually check the closed issues and
the closed pull requests
this is really important see which ones
were closed and were they closed in a
friendly and collaborative way
does someone write thank you very much
for making this contribution but
unfortunately this doesn't match with
x y and z or was it just closed of no
comment so therefore the contributor
doesn't realize why their changes
were not accepted it's really important
to contribute to an inclusive project
because otherwise it will be
disheartening if your hard work
gets closed for no reason if it's
something they don't want
which is why you should raise an issue
first at least there's a good reason why
it wasn't accepted
and then hopefully have given you
motivation or an idea of other things
you can
contribute to in the future to have it
accepted and merged another tip that i
found recently that i really want to
share with you is if you found the
project that you want to contribute to
for example this one search the project
for to-do's
a lot of the time people put to-do's in
the projects and never actually raised
the issue
and these to-do's get forgotten about
maintainers in the community will really
appreciate if you find a to-do
raise an issue and if you can make the
change and make the improvement to
remove the to-do
everyone will really appreciate it let's
go through the markdown basics
so that you know how to write a really
good issue and really good pull request
so you can stand out
it's important for you to know the eight
different markdown syntax
a single hash is a heading one and that
gets converted
to a h1 in html and you can do
two hashes to create a heading two and
that goes all the way down to heading
six
that'll be six hashes then you can write
normal text
normal text and then if you want
something bold
you would wrap it in double asterisks on
either side
and if you want italic text it's a
single asterisk
on each side if you want a strikethrough
it's double tilde on both
sides let's have a look how that renders
and you can see
preview at how it renders what other
awesome things can you do so you can
also do lists so we can do an unordered
list this is item one
item two with the sub list sub item 2b
we can preview that and you can see how
it's indented with the sub list as well
and we can also do an ordered list
and a trick here is not to do them one
two and three is actually just to do one
on all of them and you may think why
the secret is the github will do the
rest for you and therefore if you move
any items around you don't have to keep
renumbering them all the time as you can
see it reads one two three
and github also uses that on the issue
list and the pull request and it's
really important to give an
overview of an issue or progress what
stage is at how much progress has been
done
and the way you do that is with square
brackets and a space in it so you can
say item one
incomplete but if you want to make item
two complete we put an x in it
and this would be complete you don't
have to write the word incomplete and
complete but you can see now
item two is checked and item one is not
if you wanna put links in you can't just
paste the link
but it might look out of place so if you
actually want to put text that is shown
that is linkable
then you would put square brackets for
the text that you want
appeared so in this case free code camp
and in the brackets you put the link
where you want to go to
so if you hit preview you can see it is
still a link and it still goes to the
same place
it's more readable and more friendly and
if you have an image that you want to
display
you can just put an exclamation in front
of it and the writing in the square
bracket will be the alt text
and then in the brackets will be the
path to the
image and that can be a local path or a
url of the internet
if you really want your issue and pull
requests to stand out you can also look
at doing code blocks and tables let me
show you
so the first row is actually the title
and we need to tell the markdown how the
table is going to be rendered it's going
to be left align
centered or right aligned and you can do
that with colon and three dashes is what
i recommend
you can actually make do more dashes to
make the table look easier to read
however as you change the column sizes
with different content
these will never be accurate so i
wouldn't worry about trying to make
the right number of dashes to suit the
column because it's always going to
change the width
as you add and remove different content
so we can left align the first column
and let's right align the second column
and now we can put in the first row so
we can say
row one a and then we can say row
one b and you separate these by pipes
and now if i hit preview you can see the
table has come through
and you can see column one is aligned to
the left and column two is aligned to
the right and you can also center a line
by putting colon either side of the
dashes
and now you can see row 1b is now
centered code blocks
this is where it's really important to
have your issue in progress stand out by
using
code blocks and there are so many
different things you can do with code
blocks
with things like syntax highlighting or
even diffs is epic let me show you
so for inline code you use a single
backtick this
is backtick and you can say console.log
and when you preview that it shows it in
grey it's not very fancy it doesn't
stand out massively so if you wanted to
stand out more
we could say example code block
you do three backticks and then you put
in the same code
and you close it with three backticks
now you can see it's a big blocks full
width stands out a lot more
but it's still not syntax highlighted so
you can do things after the first three
backticks you can do things
where you put in the language so if it's
markdown or if it's
javascript or typescript or ruby or php
or python whatever it is
and when you render it actually
highlights it this doesn't show it very
well
but you can see the log has changed a
different color and if you're adding and
removing things and you want to show
what changes there should be
then rather than doing two blocks like
for example
if i said const data equals
this if you want to show the differences
before and after
in say an issue or in a discussion then
to have two code blocks is quite verbose
let me show you
and show you a really awesome way to
look really professional
so we have two code blocks they are
syntax highlighted but you can see
before and after it's not very easy to
see what changed you just gonna notice
the brackets are changed from an array
to an object but the way to look awesome
you can combine that into one code block
and the way you do that is you put both
of them in the same code block and
actually the type becomes a diff rather
than the language
the line you want to take away you put a
minus and the line you want to add you
put a plus
and when you render that you can see
it's really highlighting
what you want to remove and what you
want to change to and that's really
awesome
it's so awesome and so powerful that
actually when you're reviewing someone's
pull request rather than saying
oh you need to change this bracket or
something like that you can actually put
in a diff in an inline comment
and the other person can just click
accept and github
will take that diff apply it to that
branch and pull request
so it makes it become very slick and
very efficient
even with the linear conversation on
github some people write a big block of
text
and you might be saying yes or no and
it's unclear to which part the paragraph
you're saying
so it is possible to do quotes and i
highly recommend that and what i mean by
quotes is this
if someone wrote i have idea one
and also idea two if someone wrote they
have two ideas in the paragraph and you
wanted to say yes to idea one and no to
idea two
if you just say you would have to write
yes and no and maybe it wasn't so
obvious which ones you're referring to
so one thing you can do that's what
someone wrote when you reply
you can quote what they said and it
appears in the quote but even better you
could split it apart remove the and
have two quotes i agree with this
i do not agree with this
and so when you preview it it's really
obvious to know what you were replying
to
otherwise the next comment that comes
back is which one did you mean it wasn't
very clear
so it's really important to keep things
efficient on github and that will help
you with chatting on stack overflow on
discord on slack
because it's important to give enough
information but not give too much that
it's a book like war and peace
because some people wonder why they ask
questions and they don't get answers
it's because their question isn't very
good
and people don't want to try and dig in
and get blood out of a stone
if you can make it really easy for
someone to understand
your question your idea your bug then
it's more likely you're gonna get help
having good communication be an issue be
on social media be on discord or slack
is a great way to get noticed and to get
into the conversation
another tip on a pull request is you
probably have raised an issue for that
pull request
i highly suggest closing the issue when
the pull request gets closed or merged
and the way you do that is
is you put a hash a bit like the heading
title but without a space
you put in the number that you want to
reference to and then before that you
put
closes or fixes and you can write more
after this
but when this gets merged closed then it
will also close the issue it reduces the
admin for the community and the
maintainer and that's really important
put yourself in their shoes try and make
their life easier when they're getting
lots of comments suggestions pull
request issues you want to make it as
efficient for them as possible
and remember you don't have to
contribute a big
pull request you need to keep it
efficient
and small as a project maintainer myself
i would rather have
more pull requests that are small
because i can merge them
very quickly in bite sizes rather than
trying to spend an
entire day going through someone's huge
pull request
so if you want to get your pull request
merged i suggest keeping it
small and concise i really believe there
is no pull request that is too small
let me give you another little gem on
pull requests if you want to get
feedback on your work sooner then i
suggest raising the pull request
but do this gem as you can see here on
the right
under the reviewer section you can
convert your pull request
to a draft that's really important it
shows the community and project
maintainers that you would like some
feedback but it's not ready for the
proper review
to get merged in so getting that
feedback early is really important start
that the conversation
in the issues and when you've made
changes start it early in the pull
request
but don't forget to convert it to draft
so people know that it's not
completely ready otherwise you're going
to get lots of comments of things you
might not have quite finished yet and
that's why it's important to have a
checklist in the description as well and
then when it's ready to have a proper
review and everything's finished
you can then convert it back to a normal
pull request and remember i
mentioned that doing a to-do list in
your issue or your pull request shows
the progress
as you can see i have four to-do's and
none of them are done and you can see
that the progress is zero
other ones have got four out of four
this really helps maintainers and the
community
look through the list of pull requests
to see what's ready for reviewing
in this section we're gonna talk about
how you can make money directly and
indirectly from open source github now
has
a sponsorship program and what that
means is people can sponsor you or you
can sponsor people
on the github platform and github takes
no commissions if you sponsor someone
ten dollars a month they're gonna get
ten dollars a month and to take that
even further
github were doing matching that meant
that if you sponsored someone
ten dollars a month github would also
give them ten dollars a month
so either they could get double or you
just half your donation and give the
other half to somebody else
because github will match it and you've
probably seen this sponsor button on
organizations and people's profiles
so if you find an organization or a
person that you really think they're
doing great work in the community you
want to support them
click on that sponsor button and give
them a small donation whatever you're
comfortable with they will really
appreciate it
that's how you can make money directly
from github so i suggest setting that up
it's free to set up on your account
i highly recommend setting that up
because you never know who wants to
sponsor you so that's the way you can
make money directly from open source
let me talk about the ways you can make
money indirectly so i have mentioned
about the networking and communication
if you do regular open source people
will then discover you and by people i
mean companies headhunters hr
departments recruiters
hiring managers they will discover you
and then
they will contact you to offer you a job
says you
getting money indirectly from open
source
and that's really important i do open
source on github and i do youtube videos
and my biggest regret about both of
those is not starting
sooner because they have both
accelerated my learning
my career my clients the money i've
earned
i cannot encourage you enough to do the
same
instead of you hunting for a job instead
of you writing a cv to match that job
why can't
the companies chase you and not even ask
for a cv
because they love your github profile
they love your
community presence so if you can write
blog posts or do youtube videos i also
highly recommend doing that
to complement your open source you can
talk about what you've learned what
you're doing you don't have to
invent something new you're probably
learning something new every day
just share that on github or on socials
and do that little and often and you
will get discovered
some techniques that i use what i'm
hiring for myself or for my clients
is i want to look at people's github
profiles there's no surprise there
but i'm not looking how amazing their
code is so if your code isn't amazing
still put it out there
i'm actually looking at their code today
and comparing it to their code
two three months ago and all i care
about is that the code
has improved in that time because that
shows me the person is still
learning and that's more important than
being an expert in one area
and also i'm looking for the person's
attitude how do they communicate and
collaborate with other people this is
why i keep encouraging you
to get involved in the conversation on
other people's issues on your issues
on other people's projects and your
projects so other people can contribute
to your projects and start the
conversation with you
and then you can communicate back it's
really important to see how people
communicate
not only as a contributor but as a
maintainer i suggest getting involved in
the conversation
if you're looking for resources to get
involved in open source contribution
free code camp have an awesome community
driven project
you can see it behind me there are
almost 150 contributors to this project
that shows
the value of this project because it's
showing different perspectives people
with different backgrounds are giving
their opinion
so this project is going to add so much
value so let's have a quick look
there are translations of this project
into so many different languages so if
english
is difficult for you then there are
different languages that you can look at
they might not quite be up to date and
also if you're familiar with some of
these languages
or even just one of these languages you
could read the english version and
update it to your language
which would really help the communities
that's a really awesome contribution you
could give back to the community and to
this project
this is translated into 11 languages if
you know any other languages then
feel free to make a contribution and
translate it into that language
it makes our community even more
inclusive even right at the beginning of
the readme
it says this is a list of resources for
people who are contributing to open
source
and if you find additional resources
please contribute a pull request what a
great way to start a readme
it has blog posts from different people
in the community and i think some of
these posts are really
interesting how to do searches searching
on github can be quite complicated there
are so many filters
tips and tricks that you can do it's
really convenient there are links here
to make it so much easier for us to
filter down the issues on github
for example first timers only now you
can see the issues across github are
filtered down with the
label first timers only and there are
open source initiatives
things like first timers only first
contributors hacktoberfest and 24 pull
requests and 100 days of code so
do have a look at those they are a great
initiative to encourage you to get into
open source
we've talked about contributing to open
source but what about project
maintainers
wait a second before you get scared and
say hey i'm new to open source
i can't be a project maintainer yet i've
barely contributed to open source
everyone who's on github
is not only a contributor is they are
actually a maintainer so you
are a maintainer as soon as you have
that one
repo on github that is public it might
just be to customize your github profile
but that is an open source repo that
anyone else in the community
could raise an issue raise a pull
request make suggestions to you
so you are actually already an open
source maintainer
and that's great because it's really
good to practice the communication
skills and the networking skills
on the other side so let's talk about
how you can get your project to stand
out
and you may think why would i want my
project to stand out i'm a bit nervous
the project isn't ready
trust me your project will never be
ready these open source projects are
living projects they're having
improvements done by you and the
community
all the time so project will never be
ready and people really like joining a
project
in the early days because they can help
guide the direction of the project
imagine waking up to 10 12 pull requests
people have made improvements to your
project
it's such an awesome feeling to have
that to think wow people have actually
spent their time
and effort to make an improvement to my
project which then becomes
our project and you build a community
around
your project and you'll learn so much
from it people will make suggestions
you don't have to accept everything but
just by having the conversation you will
learn
so much more around the technologies
you're using in your project
and libraries and frameworks that you
might not even be aware of yet
to make your project more inclusive and
more enticing for people to get involved
and contribute
the first thing i recommend doing is
going to the insights tab
from the insights tab you have a set of
tabs down the left hand side
and then go to the community tab from
here you can really
see how you can make your project more
inclusive does it have a description
does it have a readme does it have a
code of conduct does it have the right
templates for issues and pull requests
does it have a license and you can do
this on other people's projects as well
so it's actually a really good way to
contribute
contributing to your own project
regularly is actually
really useful it shows the github
algorithm that your project is alive
and all the stats on github also look
healthy and people want to contribute to
projects that are moving forward not
projects that are dead
or archived without having the archive
flag on the repo
so don't try and spend an entire weekend
doing one giant
commit to your project i highly
recommend every day
every few days doing small changes to
your project therefore people can
understand the changes that are
happening
do a commit for each value that you add
to your own project
and if there are people who are more
junior than you who want to get involved
in your project and even if you're new
to tech
this is really valuable those people
with a fresh pair of eyes
will actually improve your projects so
much because they will
show you and highlight what parts don't
make sense for newcomers
and they might make sense to you because
you built the project to really
embrace the feedback from the community
and from people who are new to tech
documentation is so important that might
scare you might think i'm not going to
write a whole
book on my project because it's changing
all the time documentation will get out
of date you don't have to write
a whole book having a readme that shows
the goal of the project
and has a quick start guide of how to
get the project running locally so
people can start making changes to your
project and get involved having a
screenshot in your readme is really
helpful it's which straightaway
shows the benefit of the project and if
you can have it deployed somewhere
so that people can go and have a play
and check it out it's also really
important you want to lower the barrier
to entry so people can get involved in
your project
as easily and as quickly as possible
automate everything
as much as you can for day one you don't
have to try and
have a perfect automation pipeline but
do start automating things
from the beginning now with github
actions it's really easy
there are a few lines of yammer config
to have github actions
to run a linter on your project to run
any checks that you want or any checks
that
you might do manually if you can
automate these then when you do have the
conversations and the pull requests with
your community
you're actually having the conversations
about the more valuable part
rather than about formatting or any of
the simple checks
that could be easily done with github
actions another great tip i can give to
you as a project maintainer is try to
respond to people as soon as possible
ideally within 12 hours and what i mean
by that is if you haven't got time to
review
an issue or discuss it or to review a
big pull request at least comment and
say look i'm really busy with work
i will try and reply this weekend but at
least the person who started the
discussion who raised the pull request
knows
that you believe in your project and
you're just busy at the moment
another great thing about being a
maintainer when you're contributing to
other projects you also realize that a
lot of these projects are done on the
side people don't do these as a
full-time
job so if you don't get a response
straight away
be patient they haven't forgotten it
they've got the notification
don't send them emails discord dms
twitter dms with links to your issue or
your progress
they've got the notification if you
don't hear back from them within a few
days a week then yes by all means
do reach out to them but don't spam them
all within the first 10 minutes
to help your project get discovered you
need to be involved in
other projects i don't just mean
contributing code to other projects as
i've been saying the whole way along
through this video
get involved in the conversation reply
to an issue
review someone's pull request and give
your thoughts and feedback and when they
see you getting involved in the
communication
they will go to your github profile and
they'll have a look at what projects you
have
that's why it's also important to
customize your github profile
let's take a look at mine as you can see
i've customized my github profile i'm
changing this all the time and if you
have any suggestions or any improvement
raise an issue raise a pull request on
my repository to customize your github
profile
all you need to do is create a repo with
the same name as your username
just like this go to the plus above and
go to new repository
and type in your username what you see
on the left have the same
on the right i've done that already so
as you can see i've got this here
and this readme is what appears on my
github profile
and in here you can put basic html and
markdown
and you can customize it regularly and
often i do get contributions you can see
i've got two pull requests waiting
to get reviewed i really enjoy seeing
people's ideas and suggestions
for my customized github profile i
actually do also enjoy contributing to
other people's github profiles
in addition to customizing your github
profile don't forget to pin the
repositories that you're most active on
your github profile you can customize
your pins up here
and then you can select the repos that
you want to be pinned you can select up
to six
open source and github is actually more
about collaboration and communication
rather than just code so it's important
to get involved
in the discussion because companies
people hiring
want to see how you communicate how you
collaborate are you a team player
do you work well with other people are
you able to give constructive
criticism to people in a friendly and
encouraging way and are you also able to
take
constructive criticism and collaborate
with people to work to a better solution
if you want to get into open source you
can up skill so you can learn
faster you can network collaborate and
improve your communication skills
and so you can get the job and money
that you deserve head over to my youtube
channel i do videos and live streams
helping you get into open source we also
have a discord channel we also have a
github organization if you'd like to
join our github organization you can
raise and issue our support repository
asking to join the organization and
we'll send you an invite this way you
can get involved in the community
straight away
the best way to learn a spoken language
is to go live in the country that speak
the language that you want to learn
so come and join our community and open
source will be like second nature to you